what's up everybody it's Warren and this
week is going to be super exciting for
superhero fans and pop culture fans not
only are we going to be getting the
Black Widow trailer which is going to be
the very first trailer of phase 4 of the
MCU but we are also going to be getting
another birds-of-prey trailer Wonder
Woman 1984 and the new James Bond
trailer as well so a very exciting time
for our community but let's talk about
that very first phase 4 trailer that is
going to be coming tomorrow Black Widow
as you might have heard me say in
previous videos the Black Widow trailer
was reported to be coming December 2nd
or December 3rd by Daniel RPK well today
is the second and it did not come but
Daniel rpk has confirmed the date and
the time for the very first teaser
trailer for Black Widow and it's going
to be coming tomorrow at 9 a.m. Eastern
Time in the u.s. so that's 8 a.m.
Central Time 7 a.m. mountain time and 6
a.m. Pacific time and if you're trying
to figure out what time it comes out in
your time zone you can simply go to
google and type it in so tomorrow at 9
a.m. Eastern Time phase 4 of the MCU
will officially begin but let's not
forget about what's coming this weekend
CC XP the Comic Con experience in South
Paulo Brazil is this weekend Kevin Feige
the president of Marvel Studios is
confirmed to be there for the panel
which is going to be 45 minutes long so
we may even get even more footage for
Black Widow at CC XP or maybe even some
footage for the Eternals but what's most
likely going to happen is that we are
going to get a lot of information about
phase 5 hopefully if we're lucky Kevin
Feige will revealed the entire slate for
phase 5 the movie announcements and the
dates so as I said a very exciting week
for the superhero community tomorrow the
first trailer for phase 4 black widow
drops and then the rest of the week is
going to be insane as well ending with
CC XP this weekend let me know how
excited you are about phase 4 officially
beginning tomorrow and about CC XP this
weekend don't forget to leave a like on
this video and subscribe with
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on the MCU and so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof